Speaker 1: And while we're on the topic of
election lies, let's talk about Lin Wood for
a moment. The Trump loving lawyer recently
got smacked down in an embarrassing way
by yet another court over his bogus
election fraud claims. Now, Lynwood,
I'm sorry he's such a comical character. If he
weren't so, you know, obviously whatever. But
anyway, Lin Wood goes out December of last year,
files multiple different lawsuits alleging fraud.
But the main ones he filed were in the state of
Georgia, where he had two separate lawsuits going,
one challenging the results of Georgia's
presidential election. The other one actually
came a little later in January, challenging the
Senate election. And in that challenge, which the
first won, the election challenge in general was
thrown out, said it was baseless. The other one
got thrown out for a second time by the Court of
Appeals late last week because they said that Lin
Wood, you have no standing in this case. So here's
what Lin Wood was actually challenging here, Wood
came out and said that because they change the
rules, the state changed the rules for signature
verification. The whole thing is fraudulent and
you cannot trust it. They didn't have the same
signature verification. For the absentee
ballots that were obviously very prevalent
in that Georgia runoff election, so
the first court that looked at this
way, way, way back in early this year said,
yeah, you don't have standing to say any of this.
The state legislature controlled by Republicans,
passed a law that gave their Republican secretary
of state, Brad Raffensperger, the ability
to change the rules for the absentee ballots
because it was in the middle of a pandemic, they
knew they were going to have a lot of absentee
ballots. They were counting on it. That is what
their election was basically going to have to be
because of the pandemic. He had the authority to
do this, the authority given to him by the state.
You therefore have no standing, Lin Wood and the
Court of Appeals last week basically told him the
exact same thing. You have no injury. You have no
actual claim of illegal activity, again, because
he was given the authority to do this. States,
as we all know, have the authority to determine
how their own elections are run without the
interference of outside forces. So, no, Mr. Wood,
you don't get to come into these courts
and tell us that something illegal happened
when all of the changes that you're actually
challenging were approved by the state.
No injury, no illegal activity, no standing for
Mr. Lin Wood, I don't know how many total court
losses this brings us to at this point with people
like Lin Wood and Giuliani and Sidney Powell.
But I can promise you they're going to continue
to lose. But of course, that hasn't stopped the
Republicans in all these states where the lawsuits
are losing from an acting, these highly oppressive
and repressive voting laws. So that, I guess,
is the silver lining for Republicans. You may be
losing the court battles, but you've won the war
on voter suppression. For now, we have to take a
quick break. I'm Ferring Cousins from Ring of Fire
sitting in for David Pakman. We'll be right back.